the state ordered closure of a valley
funeral home has come to an end but the
business is still closed heights funeral
home and cremation had a long list of
violations and denise was forced to shut
down yeah in fact our viewers might
remember over the summer heights which
is located there in henderson was put on
suspension after those issues were
uncovered joe moller joining us now live
from sunset near boulder highway to
explain why the future of this funeral
home is still so uncertain joe
the executive director of the funeral
board says heights remains closed as the
owners never renewed their licenses that
were up in the fall but taking a look at
this building tonight it's a little dark
but normally there are signs on that
wall there that say heights funeral home
those are no longer there the funeral
board is still deciding what will happen
to the operators of this business
i knew that something was off ashley
brazile's father was cremated at heights
funeral hall after we paid for
the cremation after that it was very
hard to get a hold of anybody she wasn't
surprised the business was put on
suspension last year when violations
were discovered one violation being
bodies incorrectly stacked on top of
each other the funeral board suspended
its license for six months what was
discussed at the meeting was the
settlement was to have the licenses
revoked for a three-year period and the
board wanted a five-year period jennifer
kant is the executive director of the
nevada funeral and cemetery services
board she says the licenses were not
renewed as the board is still in the
process of negotiating a settlement for
remaining cases and violations
additionally they talked about another
five-year time period that
eric lee's license he won't be able to
manage
a facility she says an agreement between
eric lee from heights and the board has
to happen if there is no agreement the
issue will go to a hearing the
settlement agreement though does
prohibit them from opening any new
locations brazil complained herself so i
put in a complaint to the funeral board
she says if you feel unhappy with the
funeral home service you can always go
somewhere else getting them transfer him
transferred would have been my best bet
cant says eric lee has another location
in trump operated by another director we
did reach out to that location to see if
we could get in contact with eric to see
if he had any plans to reopen heights
but we have not heard back from him yet
the funeral board is set to meet next on
may 24th reporting live in henderson
this evening joe mulder live local now